pero la ley más restrictiva sobre el
aborto en eeuu entró en vigor la noche
de este miércoles el gobernador de
oklahoma kevin state firmó la nueva ley
que prohíbe el aborto en cualquier
momento de la gestación el embarazo sólo
se interrumpirá en caso de emergencia
médica o si el resultado de una
violación o de incesto denunciado ante
las autoridades el gobernador
republicano steve publicó un comunicado
que dice
prometí a los ciudadanos de oklahoma que
como gobernador firmaré cada propuesta
legislativa pro-vida que llega a mi mesa
y estoy orgulloso de cumplir esta
promesa hoy desde el momento que la vida
empieza con la concepción tenemos la
responsabilidad como seres humanos de
hacer todo lo que podamos para proteger
la vida del bebé y la de la madre esto
es en lo que creo y en lo que la mayoría
de ciudadanos de oklahoma creen
[Música]
la ley es parte de la política de los
republicanos de restringir el derecho al
aborto en los estados donde gobiernan y
llega tras la filtración de las
deliberaciones de los magistrados de la
corte suprema que pretenden revocar la
sentencia de roe versus wade que
legalizó el aborto a nivel federal
cincuenta años atrás y que continúa
dividiendo el país anualmente se
practican 600.000 abortos legales en
eeuu 5000 de estos en oklahoma